Tommy asks 13 thoughts of being an
entrepreneur you say you focus on top
line versus bottom line why Tommy you
know one thing I think a lot of
entrepreneurs do especially ones that
are just starting company since I invest
in so many of them that completely blows
me away is they start looking to drive
margin profit very early on the reason I
always focus on top-line revenue and
something I did in my dad's business and
something that AJ felt when I started
going full-time on the Vayner front was
you could always drive your profits
higher eventually but when you got a
moment in time and when I run businesses
I tend to innovate and I tend to be
slightly ahead of the market and and the
market eventually catches up to me and
then that's the good thing that's the
moment when you gets exciting people
start believing in social media
marketing or believing in internet
e-commerce wine businesses or we're
believing in Australia New Zealand South
African wine I have to really run fast
and grab as many customers because I'm
slightly ahead then three four five six
seven eight years down the line I can
start driving profit you could always
start cutting costs raising prices at
any time but land grabbing more
customers gives you leverage of the
scale that you'll - I need to convert
that and so I think people go in for the
the right hook the peripheral the big
right hook a lot of times way too early
sometimes to appease investors sometimes
because they just want to start buying
boats and Rolexes and I just you know
I'm just kind of pushing and building
leverage for the long term oh crap wait
subscribe I need subscriptions because I
can't push this many right hooks in
social so subscribe